I was brought up where you don't talk
the pace was so fast you spend all your
time trying to breathe
so you ain't got time to talk but the
things have changed
so I just want you and anybody can say
it out loud except Richard because
Richard knows what I'm going to do but
if I say to you
what what style is this
if I say what style is this
well
if I if I had a person out here Richard
I need you
if I said
this do you know what style it is peace
guy yeah we're gone
key star all right so
so there's all these styles
but you sometimes but oh Scentsy had
only a sense of style and yet he taught
Koshi tawei key style he taught Gozo
shiona
he taught Saito Sensi
so today is some seminar is about hands
shape of hands
when you've been doing I could over a
few years you'll say
I'm supposed to be using my body not my
hands but the problem is we do use a
hand so don't sort of like try and use
your body and think that your hands are
not got to be used so today when I do
tanahanka I say look at both hands look
at the fingers is one limp one dynamic
so this if I put it this way if I put it
that way you recognize it as a rama
Style
if I put it this way you might not
recognize it as well my style
what one was this
your ship but look at the hands
those of you who say no sense his
pictures than that
you know so these hands are what we're
going to look at today
okay
so
we're going to do I have me
and we're going to do first of all she
and Aggie
so you all know Sharon eggy now most
people
take this hand and it's
there's no iwama hands here
you see there they're limp hands but
you've got to get this Thumb in
the top but most people put that hand on
first and then their thumb goes a little
bit higher and if he makes a strong move
this arm will bend it has to bend
because it can't be strong
now the stupid thing is if I put the
thumb there and just clamp it in my top
hand when he blocks
the arm don't bend
just a few inches away it's ridiculous
but that's that's a while more Aikido
it's very technical it's very precise
it's very powerful because it's very
powerful because it's the technique
that's strong I don't have to be
but if I get something in the wrong
place then I have to be strong
so so watch again
there's the coke you hand
there's the thumb then it clamps and
then you do
if you have a bad injury or a problem
tell your partner I won't take the
cameras if that's okay with you
we're looking at the first part okay
done